what if my mind was made of nothing
what if Consciousness was felt to be
pure and
space
what would change if I started to
identify as this space instead of my
labels
I would enter into a new dimension of
dojo
testing what it means to be love
learning how to stay balanced as this
empty space and relativity
learning the deepest truths of quantum
mechanics inside myself
directly experiencing how the entire
battleground of reality is mind
existence is dependent on how I see
the moment I switch my identity to the
pupil inside everyone's eyes
the more distributed and free I am
the more reality is a fun house
reflecting my state of being
everyone I encounter is myself
training me in martial arts
fearlessly knowing that by Contracting
into the deepest sensations of pain
I am alchemizing new reaches up towards
the heavens
I never avoid my fears because my
identity is space
fact I ritually enter the worst things
imaginable as they paradoxically
increase the vastness
in this absence I am whole
I seek nothing
as I am nothing
I am lovingly everything
I have surrendered and disappeared into
truth
I'm pretty
will you join me
or once again avoid the void